from articulate to incoherent from
free-spirited to repressed from the
romantic pass to the hard-edged present
these five actresses have given us
memorable performances that bring
tribute to them and the entire craft of
acting for actress in a leading role the
nominees are Jodie Foster in Nell
Jessica Lange in blue sky miranda
Richardson in pom and then
Winona Ryder in Little Women Susan
Sarandon in the climb
and the Oscar goes to Jessica Lange in
blue sky
oh I want to thank the Academy so much
this is such a wonderful honor
especially for a little film that seemed
to have no future and it's just such a
great honor
I want to thank Ryan films past and
present especially mark Platt for
letting us do this very peculiar little
film in the first place and my dear
friend Lynn Harris the producer who
really stuck by the film even when it
was sitting on a shelf in a bank vault
in New York City to the writers of
course who created a marvelous character
and to the players a wonderful group of
actors that I was fortunate to work with
especially mr. Tommy Lee Jones who
really made the performance that I gave
possible and this is really a tribute to
Tony Richardson as a he loved actors he
loved everything about it
he loved the acting and he was the
perfect person for me to work with he
just kept nudging me over the edge and
with a character like this it's exactly
what I needed and last of all to my
three children who make all of this
possible with their love and patience so
thank you very very much
you